bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur ft france alors qu'ils sont
les vos informations sur cette nouvelle
affaire de violences policières qui
entachent les rangs de la police à paris
alors ni plus ni moins que celles qui
sont eux qui ont été diffusés en fait
dans la presse je pense que
l'information est relativement complexe
et complète d'ailleurs c'est à dire qu'à
ce stade comment dire on a une parole
contre une autre
c'est à dire qu'on a des blessures donc
une personne qui se présente comme
victime d'un viol par pénétration
digitale
parce qu'il faut rappeler que le viol
c'est pas simplement au plan juridique
en tout cas une relation sexuelle non
consentie
ça peut être également une pénétration
par donc un rapport sexuel à une
pénétration digitale ou également par un
objet ça peut également être un rapport
sexuel imposé par la contrainte
contraint psychologique ou physique
donc voilà juridiquement on en est là
aujourd'hui ce jeune homme prétend avoir
été victime de violences à caractère
raciste et de viol au moment de ce qu'on
appelle une fouille à corps une fouille
à corps c'est globalement une mesure
assez exceptionnel en fait parce que bon
quand une personne est interpellé quel
que soit le motif
avant d'être placé dans une geôle de
garde à vue elle est systématiquement
fouillés et j'irai dépourvu de ses
effets personnels c'est-à-dire qu'on lui
retire ses lacets sa ceinture et tous
ses effets personnels son téléphone ses
papiers et tout cela est consigné
justement dans un casier personnel est
listé de façon très scrupuleuse sur le
registre des gardés à vue
ensuite effectivement en principe
puisque la personne est dépourvu de tout
ce qu'elle possède sur l on est censé
faire un minimum de vérifications pour
voir si effectivement dans son intimité
c'est à dire que dans son caleçon dans
ses sous vêtements
elle dissimule quelque chose ça peut
être un objet dangereux
ça peut être un simple lasserre qui peut
malheureusement parfois être utile
dans certains cas des gardés à vue par
exemple on fait des tentatives de
suicide et ça peut être des matières
stupéfie nantes des objets dangereux au
cours de ma carrière par exemple j'ai
déjà eu le cas d'un gardé à vue qui
avait dissimulé un briquet un petit
briquet dans son rectum
celui ci n'avait pas été fouillé
scrupuleusement il a mis le feu à son
matelas pendant sa garde à vue vous
voyez ça reste quelque chose d'assez
complexe mais la fouille systématique
donc par contre alors là où ça devient
beaucoup plus complexe c'est qu'il y a
dans certains cas particulier ce qu'on
appelle une fouille à corps qui est de
la compétence exclusive des officiers de
police judiciaire or il se trouve qu
aucun de ces deux policiers n'est au pgi
un dock c'étaient de simples gardiens de
la paix agents de police judiciaire et
donc alors selon les accusations
il aurait refusé lui il admet avoir
refusé de se soumettre à une
vérification c'est à dire en gros se
déshabiller et tous et pour montrer que
son rectum était vide de tout objet
dissimulé et donc il aurait été selon
ses déclarations contraint par la force
et pénétrer dans son intimité aux fins
de vérification et docks alors c'est une
exclu une accusation extrêmement grave
qui va être de toute façon vérifier au
cours de l' enquête puisque il faut
savoir que tous les lieux de privation
de liberté et ça c'est réglementaire
c'est à dire les prisons dans certains
cas en tout cas les parties communes des
prisons les centres de rétention
administrative et les locaux de garde à
vue font l'objet d'une vidéo
surveillance alors que de toute façon on
aura très rapidement je pense l'issue de
cette affaire
mais le vieux lille a été attestée par
un certificat médical tout de même
alors pour rester très neutre je pense
que le certificat de mickeal dit autre
chose
le certificat médical qui a été élaboré
par les unités médico-judiciaires
attestent de la présence d'une blessure
au niveau justement de la zone péri
annales concernant ce monsieur mais
après vous savez on n'a aucune certitude
sur la façon dont cette blessure aurait
été causé et ça va être l'objet
justement de cette enquête
en l'occurrence en principe je sais on
il m'a été visualise adn étaient en
cours
or il faut dissiper est né pouvait bien
sûr tout à fait dans le cadre d'une
enquête administrative et judiciaire
mais en fait l enquête de l'igpn elle
vise justement à démontrer la réalité
des faits dont il faut savoir que par
exemple pour les fouilles à corps les
policiers sont théoriquement équipés de
gants en latex donc alors on me dit que
dans le cadre de cette enquête
une analyse adn un prélèvement adn a été
opérée justement sur la victime pour
voir si justement ces déclarations
corroborent avec le résultat des
analyses
puisque celui ci prétend avoir été
pénétrés digitalement sans que le
policier n'utilise un gant en latex donc
écouter ça me paraîtrait effectivement
extrêmement grave mais on va pour le
moment attendre les conclusions de
l'enquêté qui peut résumer il suffisait
de la mauvaise volonté de l'igpn et sur
les accusations de racisme
alors là effectivement bon ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les vidéos surveillance
des locaux de garde à vue ne sont pas
sonorisés
c'est à dire que ce sont uniquement des
images de vidéosurveillance donc là
encore une fois on sera parole contre
parole
si ce n'est que dans ce commissariat on
a déjà eu des précédents c'est à dire on
a eu par exemple ouvrage de valentin
gendreau qui est sorti l'été dernier qui
attestait justement d'une forme de
racisme ordinaire au sein des effectifs
de ce commissariat
même si on peut pas les incriminés dans
leur globalité on a également eu en
décembre
une vidéo qui a été exfiltré sur une
scène de bizutage qui concernait un
policier noir qui étaient menottés aux
grillages et qu on recouvrait de farine
blanche
on a eu quelques affaires bon c'est un
commissariat qui avait également fait
parler de lui parce qu'il renfermait des
cas de gale
en 2018 il me semble et de qu'il avait
été ferme et justement les locaux
avaient été fermées au public et aux
fonctionnaires parce que certains
présentaient des symptômes de la gale
qui est quand même une maladie
moyenâgeuse doute coûté c'est une
situation précaire extrêmement grave qui
malheureusement est redondante dans ce
commissariat d'où tu sais il appartient
aux autorités de la préfecture de police
d'une part de faire la lumière sur cette
affaire mais de faire en sorte
peut-être que ce commissariat puisse
offrir aux administrés une meilleure
qualité de service public en tout cas
laissé il remonte au 5 avril est omis le
jeune homme a donc présumer agressé
s'est adressé à des médias
d'investigation comme un streetpress on
voit ici le rôle important quand même
que peuvent jouer les médias pour
révéler ce type d'affaires est ce que
c'est une marque de défiance selon vous
envers la justice en matière de
violences policières présumées
alors effectivement oui parce que parce
qu'on constate ces dernières années
c'est que malheureusement on peut pas
compter sur la neutralité du ministère
de l'intérieur pour mettre en évidence
les violences policières et les cas de
racisme policiers quand ils existent
quand ils sont avérées ou tout
simplement soupçonnées donc si vous
voulez c'est cet avènement de la presse
concernant les affaires de violences
policières et de racisme dans la police
ne sont finalement que le symptôme d'une
institution qui dysfonctionnent qui a du
mal à regarder ses propres démons
j'irai en face et admettre justement ces
dysfonctionnements dans leur globalité
et donc heureusement que les médias
d'investigation telles que ceux que vous
avez cités existe et mais en théorie ce
jeune homme aurait dans un jeu dans un
monde parfait eu à faire confiance à
l'institution judiciaire et à l'igpn
pour faire la lumière
mais malheureusement aujourd'hui cela
s'avère insuffisant et nombre de
victimes présumées préfèrent s'adresser
à la presse par sécurité pour
contraindre les institutions à
fonctionner normalement
bon je rappelle que l'igpn a été saisi
avec une plainte contre x a été déposée
pour violences volontaires par personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique pour
viol donc et atteinte à l'intimité de la
vie privée
c'est ce qu'a indiqué le parquet merci
beaucoup en tout cas à vous noah manoir
rappelle commercial chroniqueur police
justice le média